the one word that sort of shoots to mind
is feedback and feedback from both sides
being able to be brave enough to share
all feedback as quickly as possible no
matter how good bad or ugly that
feedback is and make sure that people
are fully up to date we've got 100% fill
rate we will find really good people but
lots of recruitment agencies can find
really good people can they deliver it
in a way that's exceptional can they
deliver it in a way that truly is
putting service at the Forefront and not
their best interest he I'm going to
introduce this candidate actually I'm
going to pull this person out because
I've got a really bad reference rather
than just waiting how it goes and and
seeing how it goes I I don't think many
recruitment agents or or Consultants are
brave enough to do that